more men than you think who are in like
these roles and have like nice jobs or
whatever they feel because they can't
talk to their women openly about like
things or what they want really that
they that will seek only girls to have
those conversations I can't believe it
and there's a lot of room but they're
not marrying though
no but they're dissatisfied in with the
girls that they're marrying because
they're not they're not they're not
dissatisfied
sexually no see which I don't understand
about guys it's a lot of dissatisfaction
no I agree that there are a lot of guys
but it doesn't necessarily right see a
guy can have multiple different women
serving different purposes
and they don't necessarily need one
woman to do everything in order for them
to be satisfied you understand what I'm
saying yeah so there are some guys that
are in such marriages and stuff like
that so we're not going to ignore those
dudes right but my point is is that you
may
a dude may not want his woman to fit a
certain that he may have
but he may fulfill that somewhere else
but it doesn't necessarily mean that
he's not satisfied with the role that
she's playing okay yeah so a dude can
have multiple different women fulfilling
different purposes and that's okay for
that particular guy but that doesn't
mean he's not possessive about the fact
that he don't want his girl to be with
another dude
you understand what I'm saying yes yeah
yeah I do think that that means that he
is dissatisfied in his relationship
which is all I was trying to say or
maybe he just has a robust sexual
appetite that requires multiple
different Lifestyles or different women
to fulfilled it but what if you're going
to have a woman that does all of that
his wifey and his
in the way that you wanted specifically
I think that if you talk to most men
considering that most men or a lot of
guys are in marriages
I think it's very rare for a dude to
find a unicorn
why do you think a lot of mentors
I think a lot of women marry their
second choice
and then they get the kids and then they
just stop putting up do you think men
married a second choice though like I
feel like everyone every man has their
first love I [ __ ] it up she got away
and that still will always be their
number one I actually I actually agree
with you um I think a lot of guys marry
their second choice too but I just think
women like we can't really be satisfied
with our second choice third choice I'm
not sure like what do you think why do
you think Titanic was such a hit think
about it women love Titanic they love
the notebook those are two
female movies why do so many women
identify with that it's the one that got
away I'm not sure
like the push and pull that toxic back
and forth that you don't know if you're
gonna have them or not that keeps people
that keeps that a lot I don't think that
guy's married a second choice I think
guys get married earlier
and then they evolve and grow to be
better versions of themselves whereas
the woman in a lot of instances
she's already hit her Peak and she's
going down and so it kind of is a thing
to where he's growing and evolving and
he's just not realizing his power
because he doesn't even realize that the
best version of him is way later in life
and then it it just turns into a thing I
think
I think and then they get out of
relationships and they're like oh my
gosh I can blossom I can actually be who
I want to be I can actually go for this
that doesn't work for you that don't
work for women that doesn't work for
women
in what way
because you're at your Peak when you're
younger see I feel like I'm at my Peak
now if I showed you a transformation
photo of what I looked like I don't
think I would have gotten the time of
day for a lot of people I'm curious I
want to see a peak based off of what
guys desire in women
and what do men desire in women and
marriage first the first thing that they
desire is that another not a lot of guys
have done what they wanted okay so
exclusivity 100 yeah Anton let's let's
be real let's be real looks is first a
guy would take a guy would take okay
[Applause]
so so I got a guy's gonna take
let's say only fans corn whatever
120 over a 320 girl 320 pounds
no I I know I know there's some
variability in the middle but to get in
the door you have to have a base level
of looks you get in the door that's why
I said it looks his first because if
yeah that has to get you in the door
guys aren't as picky a lot of guys
though earlier that's my fate everything
a lot of guys earlier in their life
though they married a person I think I'm
29 I'm glad there's proximity too
lighter so that that's just my face but
I look tired I wasn't like I don't know
I just got red hair
you think I look like that right now
don't insult me like that because you
look like tired with like no makeup like
that's what I think it like you look
better now right I think I'm like
glowing I think the way that is the
Playboy
so you like how I look
I want to see where like I would I was
heavier too and I'm five two so it
makes me pretty compact
but a lot a lot of these guys if you
look at a most guys wives
they're normal yeah you probably look
better now yeah they're just normal
girls oh for sure you don't have to I
feel like
uh the girls that get married sometimes
are not anything special like look like
looks wise because I think a lot of guys
want more of like security and safety
like not know knowing their woman is
picking them and is loyal to them so I
don't think looks are as important I
think when like maybe I have a question
why do you think that men cheat on
uglier girls
and then they'll and cheat with like a
six oh because she's there in willing
right no I I remember this day it was
like the day I realized I had to worry
about the ugly girls too I was like oh
my God it's hot yeah I'm almost like if
you cheat on me with like someone who is
hotter then I'm like you know what I
understand yeah like that was tempting
and maybe that's the hottest girl you've
ever been with and that's a situation
whereas like if you're with somebody
who's like actually loving you giving
you everything that you want and then
you decide to like go to for no reason
and you just like ruin your relationship
like I'm like what the hell like that
hurts that's like itchy deep she was
just like well and that's just some men
are yeah yeah men are really not built
to be turning now
[Laughter]
to be honest
[Music]
okay so if you're in a relationship or
you're married and some girl walks up to
you she's like hey you want
I mean instinctually I'll be like yeah
right emotionally now logically I'm like
okay well let me weigh the options let
me think about it right are you gonna
tell my wife you know you have to
balance it out it's all you know you
gotta you got to make a a calculated
decision but if we're honest if it walks
up to a man's like you know do you want
to hit there's gonna be a part of that
man you know of course right
I have a six kids music
five times I'm gonna think about that
but it's about having the control and
willpower that's confident though
confidence
up 20 grand right
I mean it's not even just though it's
like I don't know you just seem like a
very sad person so I am and I think that
uh I think that Sexual Energy though is
also Creative Energy and so it
channeling being able to control your
sexual energy and use that energy for
like creation whether it's creating a
baby a family a home art painting us
podcasting like you can Channel all that
so I think that's like what we did when
we were celibate it was like okay like
that build up of being celibate you
think it was easy no I was like
I was like scratching being like how the
[ __ ] am I gonna go longer than this
month and then it gets easier and then I
through that gained way more self-worth
and I was able to Channel all the energy
and I was like writing comedy and like
doing things so you feel like okay
actually I was gonna ask you this
earlier you feel like through you feel
better as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible